good afternoon i'm assistant sheriff
andrew walsh i'm here to brief you today
on the additional details that we know
with regards to the officer-involved
shooting event that occurred on tuesday
september 21st 2021
this is officer-involved shooting number
six for 2021.
this is the third fatal officer-involved
shooting we've had so far this year
compared to the same time last year we
had 15 officer-involved shootings seven
of which were fatal
this event was called in as a battery
with a deadly weapon at 9 23 am on
september 21st 2021
the officer-involved shooting occurred
in the 300 block of south 11th street
las vegas nevada 89101
in the downtown area command and you can
see the image of this neighborhood on
the screen to my left
the involved officer is officer zachary
adam he is 41 years old and has been
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department since 2006. in this incident
officer adam was in was armed with a
larue tactical 308 rifle the
investigation revealed that officer adam
filed fired one round during this
incident
officer adam is assigned to the homeland
security division specifically as
assigned to the special weapons and
tactics bureau the swat team
the suspect in this incident was
identified as trent xavier leech he's he
was a 30 year old white male adult he
was five foot seven and weighed 200
pounds and mr leech's photograph is on
the screen to my left in this incident
mr leach was armed with a black
semi-automatic beretta apx nine
millimeter handgun and the investigation
revealed that he fired approximately 20
rounds during this incident
if he had survived mr leach would have
been charged with battery with a deadly
weapon assaulting a public officer with
a deadly weapon resisting a public
officer with a deadly weapon
discharging a firearm at or into an
occupied vehicle and discharging a
firearm from at or into an occupied
structure
the details of the officer involved
shooting are as follows on tuesday
september 21st 2021 at approximately 9
23 a.m the las vegas metropolitan police
department dispatch center received a
call from a citizen reporting that there
were two males in an argument and that
one of the males was armed with a
handgun
the address given by the caller was the
400 block of south 11th street
the male with the handgun was later
later identified as trent xavier leech
the two
las vegas metropolitan police officers
that were in the area investigating a
vacant property that needed to be
boarded up
responded to the area and found mr leach
and the other male
arguing in the alley near east 11th
street
the officers attempted to detain mr
leach but he refused and he fled on foot
and ran away from the officers as they
attempted to contact him
the officers initiated a flip suit and
followed mr leach until he made his way
into a vacant building located in the
300 block of south 11th street
the officers quickly recognized the need
to set up a perimeter on the building
and treat this situation as a barricaded
armed subject
our officers are trained to slow the
momentum and call in additional
resources in situations like this to
assist in de-escalating the situation
and attempting to communicate with the
suspect hopefully bringing incidents
like this to a peaceful resolution
shortly after swat and crisis
negotiators arrived a different male
that had been sleeping in the vacant
building came out and confirmed that mr
leech was inside the building and he was
armed with a handgun
our swat negotiation team attempted to
communicate with mr leach for several
hours and at some point during this
attempt to negotiate mr leach began
shooting from inside the building toward
the officers
through the cross of the barricade mr
leech fired approximately 20 rounds
and there were photos on the screen of
the bearcat from that swat utilizes
which you can see was struck by gunfire
and i believe there's a photograph of a
residence that's a second story window
of an apartment located directly to the
south of the building where mr leech was
that was occupied and struck by gunfire
during this incident
mr leach's reckless and dangerous
actions not only endangered the lives of
the officers but the lives of citizens
who live in the neighborhood at
approximately 2 33 p.m
while using the door frame of the church
that leads to the backyard
mr leech used the door frame as cover
and pointed his firearm towards the
officers
in response to mr leech pointing his
firearm at officers swat officer adam
fired one round from his rifle striking
mr leech
at this time a team of swat officers
then approached mr leech to provide
medical aid and medical personnel
pronounced him deceased at the scene
we'll now play some videos from this
incident the first video you're going to
see is from the actual initial contact
between the patrol officers from the
downtown area command and mr leach and
the original victim in this crime
hey come here
[Music]
that's the main guy with the fourth
gotcha
come here
give me your hand
get your hands out of your pocket
come on bro you're not even in trouble
here let's go
what are you gonna do
come here
let's go come here
you're just gonna make it worse bro come
on
talk to me
you're not in trouble
come on
just come here bro
so as you can see from that video that's
where the officers originally contacted
mr leach he ran from the original scene
and then was located in the alley just
about a block away
and you could see in that video where
the officers are attempting to
de-escalate the situation by shouting
commands at him and you could also hear
mr leech in that video yell shoot me now
this second video now is taken from
inside the structure where mr leach was
barricaded and we could play that from
here
so in this video you can see mr leech is
armed with a handgun and he comes into
the room where we had a robot
and he climbs on the robot and disables
the robot
and he has a close-up view of the
firearm
and in this last video this is moments
before the officer filed the ram fired
the round and you'll see the firearm
come out from behind the door pointed in
the direction of the swat officers and
the officers that had set up containment
on the building
and as i said earlier this occurs at the
end of mr leech firing approximately 20
rounds from inside of the structure
and that's the same video that's the
same prior to the shot being fired you
can see mr leech standing in the doorway
this is taken from one of our robots
that was deployed and you can see him
reaching out from beyond the door jamb
and pointing his firearm at the officers
and that concludes our briefing
we did have drones and robots deployed
but in this instance what the footage
you see here is from the robots
yes and you can get that from our
records bureau that's available upon
your request how close were the officers
when he's pointing his gun out
i think we came up with 40 feet was the
measurement of where the sniper was
where's the 170 yards 107 yards
207 feet
we can ask for the specifics
uh i'm not going to discuss the criminal
history it's just something that in
these briefings where in the past we
discussed criminal history and we're
vilified for talking about someone's
criminal history so that's available
upon you can go to our records bureau
and through the normal channels because
we
we're just not going to do that
right no we had no civilians injured
luckily in this incident uh only
the first civilian that mr leech had the
encounter with he was struck in the face
with firearm by mr leach so that is
where one of the counts of
would have would have applied
to him it was we had a civilian victim
but not from the structure
not from the firing inside the structure
those residences as close to they
weren't as how many rounds were being
fired were very
pro it's problematic for us to attempt
to
evacuate those so folks were sheltering
in place
and you could see how close they were
any charges for the other
person involved in that
fight or any idea no he was a victim
all right
thank you all very much